welcome back to cbs morning's our next
guest the multi-talented billy porter
has won an emmy a grammy and a tony in a
trailblazing career stretching more than
30 years now he is sitting in the film
director's chair for the first time
porter directed the coming of age
romantic comedy called anything's
possible it follows a confident young
trans girl named kelsa as she navigates
her senior year of high school and falls
in love with her classmate carl in this
clip kelson call talk during art class
take a look
no way that that's so good
yeah you can have it really
yeah
you're so nice
oh man
yes you are
i remember last year joey zhang made a
ceramic soccer ball and put in the kiln
after he left he grabbed it booked a
hole in it so it wouldn't explode with
the heat yeah well maybe i was trying to
protect my egyptian fan spot from the
detritus
you were already glazing your egyptian
fiance spot joey was the only one still
sculpting joey's my friend not
you're perpetually a nice
there's nothing wrong with that
billy porter joins us right now good
morning billy how you doing good morning
good morning i'm so happy to be here
we're supporting with all of you on this
beyonce day on this beyonce
you said you haven't listened to it yet
i haven't seen it yet i've been watching
her on that horse for two weeks that's
right that's right like the rest of the
world that crystal horse yeah we're
excited to have you now this is your
first time making your film directorial
debut yeah you said that you've been
waiting for the right moment the right
project yes you said on page one you
knew that this was it what did you find
in this story that made you want to take
the sleep into that chair well first of
all this story found me okay
you know when you put stuff out into the
universe
words have power manifest it comes back
that's right 20 years ago i started
talking about i wanted to be a film
director okay christine vashon
um
you know of killer films and
you know the queen of queer cinema
um called me
with the script
uh her partners dj hinojosa and uh
i'm sorry dj guggenheim david hanojosa
and um from page one
it was about trans joy
trans celebration right the normalizing
and the humanizing
of the other right and we know what's
going on right now and we know how
necessary
those kinds of stories are so we haven't
seen a story like this before billy no
you know i had to be part of the appeal
too oh my god it's about a black
empowered
high school
teenage trans girl
you know who is she gets a boyfriend
she goes to college she's going through
the regular normal
you know um emotions and emotions that
you know every teenage girl goes through
you know
in high school and it was just
you know it's such a beautiful story and
we've never seen it before right it also
has a non-traditional ending yes don't
give that away i'm not i'm not
we're not going to wait
i've just said non-traditional that
could mean many things yes
non-traditional ending
in that
um
don't give it away not gonna yeah i'm
trying it's hard right i'm trying to
figure out but that attracts you know
it's mature yeah
the the kids it shows
the maturity of
the younger generation and i think you
know in the spirit of the old john
hughes movies which is what i
which is what came to my mind first when
i was reading it yeah you know one of
the tenets of that
is that
the the kids are taken seriously right
there you go right we they their their
emotions their issues their all of it is
taken seriously
and um we have to yeah because they are
our future
you know
so you've shot the film on location in
pittsburgh yes where you grew up yes
describe the pittsburgh of your
childhood you and your authentic self
now what was it like when you were a kid
um you know
pittsburgh was always a wonderful place
to grow up
you know yes i had a lot of trauma i'm
moving through that i'm not talking
about that no more because what has
happened
since
leaving
and watching the city
pivot
and repurpose
you know it used to be steel
you know our government officials came
in and through the decades pivoted
and changed
you know there's so much industry there
whether it's
technology
uh medicine the arts arts especially the
arts the arts has always been there and
you know it's just magical yeah there
it's a very very progressive
city i got to um
you know make this movie
about progressive issues essentially
um in my hometown the town that raised
me
um
all of the most of the uh
ancillary characters
you know supporting characters are
people you know people from my childhood
who are either actors and actresses that
i performed with in my youth who are
still doing it or my mentors you know
what i think i think you did pittsburgh
proud i think you did yourself proud you
know you're very known for your fashion
and you said you had a specific vision
for fashion in this movie as a matter of
fact we were all talking what's billy
gone word
nate always looks good but even nate
kicked it up a notch
so even nate who always looks good
kicked it up a notch for you what was
your vision for the fashion for this
movie and i always liked the vision for
yourself too yeah i you know what i
wanted to be sure
to embrace
was
how to visually
stimulate right
you know how to visually create
support this aspirational
story yeah you know because
it really speaks to what we should be
what we could be and what we should be
and speaking of that billy you know when
it comes to trans joy and trans
celebration you know part of that is
authenticity yeah being true to self yes
um so and that's something that you have
embraced but have you always embraced
that you know i want to give you
opportunity to speak to individuals that
might be struggling with being true to
self or be being authentic like was it
always like this for you or did it take
time it it took time
the goal was to always be authentic
um
you know at the beginning of my career
i was told that my queerness would be my
liability wow
and it was
for decades and in the middle
of living through that
i really began to understand oh well i
was watching oprah yeah and she had uh
elania van sant and uh maya angelou on
and they were talking about
shifting one's intention to service
and when
it becomes about service everything will
work itself out and literally i went to
the mirror in my bathroom and said what
how what the service look like for me in
an industry and quite frankly a world
yeah that is inherently narcissistic but
billy you never gave up just no you
never get it and it hit me like a ton of
bricks it's your queerness it's the
thing that everybody is telling you is
your liability it's the thing that your
church is banishing you for that your
government is shaming you for it's all
of the things that everyone around you
is telling you
won't work and now it's one of your
biggest strengths it's the superpower
you know i'm so
i'm so blessed to have been given
a second chance right this is my second
chance i get to be authentic yeah
speaking of authenticity you shared with
the world a year ago that you are hiv
positive yes talk to me about that and
the what you had to tell yourself before
you stepped to the world to explain and
do you regret being so open no
not at all not at all you know
there's a shame component
that comes with being queer um
you know
i came out in 1985
we went straight to the front lines to
fight for our lives during the aids
crisis
um
[Music]
kovid
taught me some things about myself the
lockdown taught me
um about
balance
and boundaries
and self-care and inside of that
self-care i started
going to trauma therapy and working on
the stuff that i never had the luxury
to really unpack
you know and so in the unpacking of that
i realized
oh i need to set myself free
and you've done that i have set myself
free and hopefully in the process
somebody else will be set free too so
once again in the spirit of service
i did that
for myself
to to set myself free
in the hopes that someone help others
set themselves free you know what thank
you billy porter anything is possible
that's
right billy porter billy porter thank
you philly are you seeing anything's
possible reporter director
oh i saw what you didn't see that gal